remove the diffuser bands
stand back Henrietta
she's alive
Hey the Bride of Frankenstein Brian I
don't know this is unbelievable she
speaks
guess there wasn't a pants option cheese
for me what a pleasant surprise
no no no no no for him
oh don't worry buddy she likes you how
long have you been in the monster field
for about four years
I'm saving up to go to veterinary school
yes yes yours no thank you
the humor extract took very rare and a
woman anywho let's get you two married
oh no I'm a lesbian got a Philips head
lying around - you're a lot of this
stuff looking pretty loose I'll go get
the torch we should burn her babe where
did I go wrong
yeah these things will come right off if
you don't screw them in tight and not
add enough estrogen elixir oh boy say go
say did I add too many pigments of
independence nice finish
you do this yourself I failed my
creation is turned against me that's
late to get sand job there is only one
option
the self-destruct lever
their help I'm good I know this is
probably weird for you but just not
interested in male monsters I did
everything right
I followed every calculation correctly
sorry you feel like I'm letting you down
but it's actually a huge letdown to
realize that the person who made you is
disappointed something so trivial sucks
actually all right well your lover's fix
so you can pull it if you want I have
the torch no there's no need for that
Henrietta mrs. Henrietta look I'm sorry
we've never met a lesbian monster Hey
what do you say we go out and scare the
hell out of some villagers I'd like that
yeah
if you play ball yeah my team's looking
for a picture well somebody gave me one
hell of an arm fantastic after you well
it looks like I could make this place
into a sex dungeon again